britain is facing a migrant crisis
and this is thought to be the
government's answer
in what seems to be a pushback drill
jets appear to follow a boat
they eventually catch up with the vessel
and surround it
seemingly trying to turn it around or
escort it back through the waters
it appears to be a training exercise
but comes after french authorities
refused to entertain the idea of
pushbacks which would direct boats back
to french
water but as the home office refuses to
confirm
many want answers
repeatedly the home secretary has been
asked for answers on this issue of the
channel crossings of people who are
coming across the channel and i was in
dover myself
in recent weeks i know how really
fragile these craft are
a short time later the jet skis were
seen escorting what looked like are
boats carrying migrants
it's the latest of many
the waters are unsafe the boats aren't
fit for purpose and the task to cross
the busiest shipping lanes in the world
despite all the odds stacked against
them more than 14 000 migrants have made
the journey this year so far
a record figure up from 8417
last year
the home office says
we are seeing an unacceptable rise in
dangerous and unnecessary small boat
crossings that's why we continue to
explore all options available to bring
these numbers down
our primary focus is on preventing
people from entering the channel
tackling the criminal gangs responsible
and protecting lives
as part of our ongoing operational
response we continue to evaluate and
test a range of safe and legal options
for stopping small boats
but those with experience say pushbacks
should never be an option these vessels
are usually poorly constructed
overcrowded
many people don't have life jackets on
board
and they have very
no navigational aids whatsoever
and
the question i have is
if a pushback goes wrong and a vessel
capsizes as i uh nearly saw when i was
at lesvos
who is going to be held responsible
the home office say it will fix the
broken asylum system through its new
plan for immigration but until then
hundreds if not thousands more will
continue to make this perilous journey
shaman freeman powell sky news